Lebanon is reopening after a two months
lockdown a major outbreak of the corona
virus appears to have been averted
but the pandemic devastated an already
collapsing economy many businesses
didn't survive it has been dead before
some of our projects we had to take the
right decisions if we need to go on we
closed Hamra on May 1st it was saddest
day in my whole life maybe
and for us we closed a wonderful place a
wonderful project that couldn't sustain
financially at all anymore many
restaurants won't be reopening with the
recent collapse of the local currency
the Libra it's become more expensive to
operate them but this sector was hit
hard months before because of Lebanon's
worst financial crisis in decades nearly
1,000 outlets have closed since
September
150,000 japanese employees are employed
in this sector translates into 150
thousand families who live from this
sector 25,000 were laid off between
October and January we don't know the
numbers now but I can tell you 120,000
employees are sitting at home today in
another challenge restaurants that are
back in business are obliged to operate
at 30% capacity to protect against the
coronavirus rising poverty and inflation
also means fewer customers restaurant
owners are asking for a relief from
taxes and loans to be reduced hotels are
also asking for assistance but the state
is close to bankruptcy the hospitality
sector used to be a pillar of the
economy contributing 10% of the GDP it's
also the biggest employer after the
public sector at least 18,000 hotel
employees have lost their jobs in recent
months losses have been accumulating for
years blamed partly on land being closed
off due to the war in neighboring Syria
as well as political instability that
has kept tourists away now the pandemic
has brought this sector to our halt
we're closing simply because we lost the
hope of you know a better tomorrow or to
continue
for 70 years the Bristol Hotel hosted
international conferences and
dignitaries never closing even during
the 15-year civil war that ended in 1990
this landmark is now a symbol of what
many describe as one of Lebanon's
darkest times senator al Jazeera Beirut